this video is brought to you by
squarespace the best way to make an
amazing website we have finally tested
all four graphics options on the brand
new macbook pros and today we have some
new findings for you guys as we go over
the performance of these machines in
terms of benchmarks different tests real
life to test like photo editing video
editing and also as far as thermals and
fan noise and i did find some new
surprises that will help you guys out
those of you guys guys that have not yet
bought one or if you just want to know
the general knowledge and how to suggest
the right model to some of your friends
and family so right here i have three
16-inch machines and along with a 14
inch the 14 inch is the base model that
has a 14 core graphics m1 pro chip in it
and then the rest of them are 16 with 16
core graphics 24 core graphics and 32
now a few times throughout this video i
will be referencing 14-inch machines
that do have more performance in terms
of graphics will be some interesting
results but in general these are the
graphics options that apple offers us
now let's start out by talking about the
cpu performance and all of these 16-inch
macbooks have the 10 core
cpus meaning they have
eight performance cores and then two
efficiency cores but the 14-inch base
model does come with an a core cpu has
six performance cores and the same two
efficiency cores so when we take a look
at things such as geekbench five
multi-core score we do see a difference
of about 30 or so in favor of the
16-inch machines now when i reference
some other 14-inch models that have
higher performance cpus
those have the same performance but we
do run into some thermal issues now as
far as single core performance it's
identical across the board so a lot of
tasks where it's really gpu focused the
cpus shouldn't be limiting them or
simple tasks now along with that if we
look at things like photo editing for
example lightroom which is going to max
out all of the cores we see that all of
the 16 inches even the base model is
2500
the performance is basically the same
and for the 14 inch one that has the a
core cpu it's not that far off from it
so if you're doing photo editing tasks
it's not that big of an improvement
going to something like a
24 core option in fact there's very
little difference there now if you're
somebody that uses say affinity photo
which is a lot more optimized to use
graphics here we start seeing a bigger
difference but there is one thing that
really surprised me and that is the fact
that the zp performance is identical
across the board even with the bent 14
inch model
and this is using their built-in
benchmark that looks at a wide variety
of different tasks in the program so
this just shows that thus this program
affinity which is very well optimized is
relying a lot more on graphics power so
when we take a look at the graphics
performance another thing we see is that
the difference between the 14 core and
the 16 core is very little but it is
there not enough for me to say that you
should upgrade to
say if you're getting the 14 inch to the
one that is unbend but even more so this
is what really shocked me is the fact
that with the m1 max the 24 core
performs almost identical to the 32 core
the difference there is what about a
thousand points or so um that is going
to be not even noticeable when you are
doing any kind of photo editing tasks so
for those of you guys out there that are
wondering which one you should get i
would definitely say go for the 24 core
model if you need the extra graphics
power now there's a couple other reasons
why you should go for the 24 core model
for example battery life we'll talk
about that in just a bit now if we take
a look at something from adobe like
adobe super resolution that's going to
give you a lot more megapixels better
detail we see this once again with
basically the same 18 seconds to enhance
this 42 megapixel raw file so the extra
cores on the 32 core aren't really doing
much here now as far as the m1 pro chips
the 14 16 core we have a couple second
difference but once again would i spend
the extra 300 bucks going uh up or maybe
even 500 bucks going from 14 to 16 if
you want that base one for two thousand
dollars no i wouldn't i would rather
wait the two seconds when you're doing
this so for those of you guys who are
doing tasks that are mostly cpu focused
with some gpu power you really don't
need the 24 or the 32 core chip in this
comparison the 14 16 versus 24 versus 32
we want to focus on tasks that really
need that graphics performance and that
is what we are going to jump into but
first i want to give a shout out to the
sponsor of this video squarespace if
you've been thinking about making your
own website squarespace is seriously the
best way to go you can make a great
looking website like we did with
literally no web making experience you
just choose from one of their great
templates customize blocks of text and
images and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple it is affordable and
ours have been running flawlessly for
years now bringing in tons of traffic
thanks to its built-in seo tools start
your free two-week trial with no credit
card required by going to
squarespace.com maxtec or by using that
custom link down below and when you are
ready to launch you will save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain i want to get started with
geekbench 5's metal test now this test
is not perfect some of these graphics
chips they don't pretty much all these
they don't scale fast enough apple wants
to save battery life but still gives us
a reference point because we're looking
at all apple chips now starting off with
a 14 core we have a score of 35 000 then
we go up to 41 000 with a 16 core so
noticeable difference up to 59 000 for
the 24 core and 68 000 for the m1 max
now you might say that looks like the
scaling is pretty good
but the thing is if we go ahead and
break that down to score or performance
per core you could see that our 14 core
gets
2530 points per graphics core or
graphics chip and then our
m1 max with 32 cores gets 2120
much less and you guys could see that in
the middle now this just shows that the
32 core option it doesn't have proper
scaling and if we went off of that 14
core base model the score for 32 cores
should be about 80
960
or if we just go off of the 24 core m1
max it would be 79
127. so that one is showing the least
amount of performance per core and that
is because of wattage limiting and
possibly thermal throttling and we'll be
talking about that here in just a sec
the next test is gfx bench and iran
aztec ruins 1440p off-screen to make
sure there's no influence based on the
screen resolution or pro motion and here
we see a nice fairly linear performance
difference so for gaming the 32 core
does actually show a pretty good
improvement over the 24 and the 16 core
not that much i don't think it's really
worth it over the 14 core and we can
also break that down to fps per graphics
core and here it actually looks pretty
dang good
all of them are fairly similar the 32
core slightly less but it's still worth
it if you want a game on one of these
machines now of course gaming is an
issue there's only a handful of games
that run natively to both metal being
optimized and also on arm for apple
silicon now i also tested the maximum
wattage or the peak amount of power that
is used to give you this performance and
on the hyacinth model we have
43.65 and the 24 core we have
38.77 meaning it actually draws more
power per core
than the 32 which is why performance on
some of these other tests um you know
it's actually not that big of a
difference next let's talk about blender
for 3d rendering i use the brand new
alpha release which is the first one
that supports metal now it got a lot
faster compared to the previous version
it will still keep getting improved but
looking at the numbers i see a couple of
things let's start off with the bmw
scene here and the 14 core is quite a
bit slower than the 16 core here and
then the 24 versus 32 core m1 max the
difference is literally just a few
seconds very little difference now the
classroom scene takes longer it's a lot
tougher of a test here and for some
reason the 14 core compared to the 16
core the difference was very very small
i'm not sure why i retested it
that is what i saw and then the
difference between the 24 and 32
also not that big of a difference i
don't know if it is worth spending the
extra money unless you just want to buy
one off the shelf but it is clear that
going from 16 to 24 is a massive jump
could also be because of memory uh but
that jump right there is almost twice
the performance going from 16 to 24 so
really really good scaling now let's get
into video editing starting off with
h.264 this is a five minute 4k project
here almost no difference comparing the
14 core and the 16 core and pretty much
no difference 24 versus uh 32 now that
is because this project even though i do
have a couple lots applied i have film
grain applied it is really limited by
the encoders and the m1 max chip has
dual encoders compared to the m1 pro and
even though we don't see double the
performance it is close we're getting
quite a bit faster performance here so
you definitely need to have at least a
24 if you want to have really fast
exports and this is the stuff that most
people work with with the amount of
facts that most people add so very great
performance now if we go to h.265 this
is the new modern codec that gives you
smaller file sizes and better quality
here we see an even bigger difference
and we have actually more than twice the
speed of export for the m1 max chips but
basically the same thing where it
doesn't matter if you go for a lower
core count you just have to have the m1
max instead of the pro and the
performance is great now when we test
something out that is not limited by the
encoders and it's not limited by cpu
performance it's raw graphics we do see
a different story this is in davinci
resolve and it is denoising 4k footage
and this is both using temporal and
spatial cranked up so it's very very
tough on the graphics and going from a
14 core to a 16 gives us just one more
frame per second
not a very big difference and then
jumping up to the 24 we jump by three
and then once again we jump by two going
up to 32 so not perfect scaling there
but if you're somebody does very heavy
effects that's only based on the
graphics that 32 core is worth it but
that's if it is only using the graphics
performance we'll talk about thermals
here
so if we go ahead and take a look at
something like prores raw which these
laptops here are the best for working
with prores or prores rap we do see a
speed improvement with the m1 max ship
over the pros
but it is not as significant as i
expected because when you're working
this is footage it also really pushes
the cpu and because of that we're not
getting double the speed only roughly 50
percent faster so and once again it
doesn't matter if you have a lower core
count or higher you just want to get the
m1 max chip now jumping up a notch to 8k
progress rod this is a tougher project
we don't get twice the performance with
the m1 max but we get close to it and
once again here you guys see that the 24
core is just as fast as the 32 core so
when you have something that is very
heavy graphics related it's maxing out
the graphics here but it also requires
cpu performance that's when thermals
come in and that is where the 32 core
really gives you no benefit but wait
until you see this this 8k canon raw
project going out to 4k hevc which is
what a lot of people do for the internet
our 24 core is actually
faster than the 32 core taking 7 minutes
and 10 seconds compared to
7.35
now how can that be how can the cheaper
one be faster and actually ran cooler as
well well because that graphics ship in
there it takes a lot of power and this
also maxed out the cpu that takes a lot
of power because of that it runs so hot
that it actually slows down the cpu from
300 to about 1 000 megahertz so
throttles the graphics and not only does
it run super hot and loud but it also
does it slower it is crazy
and then if we take a look at the
difference between the 14 core and 32
core we do see a difference of about a
minute and a half getting close to there
so that scaling is actually pretty good
because also the cpu is being a
limitation there i don't really think
it's the graphics um so there you guys
go you see that a 24 core can actually
beat out a 32 core model now what is
even more interesting than that to me
is that when we take a look at the base
16-inch macbook pro the one that's kept
in stock most of the time 2500
it actually matched the 14 inch model
that has a 32 core m1 max with 64 gigs
of ram i spent forty one hundred dollars
for this mac and a twenty five hundred
dollar one that's half the graphics
cores and a quarter of the ram had the
same exact 10 minute export time and
that just shows you how much these
14-inch macbooks can throttle and not
only that this is when we can talk about
fan noise as well
because the 16-inch one it took just the
same time 10 minutes it ran quieter as
well quite a bit quieter now in general
if you're looking at these machines if
you want a silent machine even if you're
pushing it
you want to get either the base model 14
inch or the base model 16 inch when you
start giving it a lot more graphics
power
you start pushing it they will spin up
now they're not crazy loud they're
better than windows machines but the
base models of both 14 and 16 are very
quiet
but what's crazy is you guys saw the
result the 2500 base 16 inch beat out
the 14 inch specked out when it does
that it actually runs the fans at about
30
it's almost silent even when the cpu and
the gpu is maxed out whereas even if you
get the base model 14 inch
two thousand dollar one 1989
that one will spin up the fiends hundred
percent even with the 14 core graphics
and the eight core processor instead of
the 10 core it will max out the fans and
be loud if you're pushing the system to
its max whereas a 16-inch model has a
lot better thermal performance a lot
better cooling and it stays pretty much
silent even under full load so if you
care about quietness running cool that
is the machine that you want to get and
then for those of you guys that want to
get the max the 24 core runs about the
same as the 32 slightly less thermals
but because it's using more wattage for
the amount of cores you get better bang
for the buck but it still can spin up
the fans and get loud and now let's go
ahead and finish off with battery life i
ran a 45 minute test using gfx bench
running all of their tests in a loop and
this really pushes the graphics it
simulates doing very heavy work starting
out with 100 battery life and after the
45 minutes our 14 inch base model had 75
battery life remaining and the 16-inch
model uh that one had 80 remaining even
though it has
more graphics performance just because
of the bigger battery now jumping up to
the 24 core m1 max that one had 70
remaining so you actually don't take
that big of a hit in terms of battery
life and the 32 had 64. so you guys see
that scaling of battery so technically
if you buy the full maxed out version
and you're really pushing it you might
be getting about two hours of battery
life maybe roughly around there
but with the base model you'll get a lot
more and then for those of you guys that
are curious about the 14 inch models
here you guys go if you get the max out
you only have 52 remaining uh which
means you're it's only going to last you
roughly hour and a half or so if you're
really pushing the machine so what do we
learned from all this testing well you
definitely get diminishing returns
getting extra graphics course from 14 to
16 most cases it's not worth it unless
you need the cpu performance and for
most video editing tasks you won't
really see that same thing goes from the
24 to 32 core
you're not going to get that much better
performance unless you're gaming which
not very many people are or you're doing
something like noise reduction and still
the difference isn't that big but it's
going to run hotter the battery life is
definitely worse on the 32 core and if
you're really pushing the machine it
could actually perform worse
than the cheaper 24 core model so the 24
core with mmo max is the bang for the
buck it is the sweet spot it is really
really well optimized for that chassis
and
if you want to save a little money get
the base one that one runs really cool
really quiet and it has insane battery
life only dropping 20 percent after 45
minutes of heavy heavy
use so my suggestion
if you can get a 16 inch you can deal
with it go for it better battery life
you get great performance and it
literally
the 16 inch 2500 one had the same
performance as a specked out 14 inch
which is just it's crazy so there you
guys go the full comparison between all
of the graphics options that you can get
let me know your thoughts down below
click that circle above if you guys want
to subscribe and help us reach our goal
of 1 million subscribers check out one
of those great videos right over there
this has been max and i will see you in
the next video
[Music]